how are you I'm good heavy yeah sing to
me Paulo I mean how does it feel to be
playing Lizzy again it feels very
surreal to be honest I mean I've been
living with this information for a few
months now so it's been very hard to
even contain my excitement but you know
she's such a big part of me in my life
and you know now she's 30 and I feel
like I'm gonna have to learn some of
like her quirky faces again but I'm
excited I've been a big part of the
process with Terry Minsky you know that
the creative process of where she's been
and what she's where she's going and
it's really it's a dream come true it
should be a mom she's not a mom no she's
not a mom yet which is fun because I
clearly am a mom and we have so many
similarities but our lives are very
different so she's been living in New
York and I'm not sure how long she's
gonna stay there but that's gonna be
like all a part of the journey so what
are the chances that Miranda Gordo Kate
Ethan could show up I mean I think the
chances are high I can't tell too much
but I think people are going to be very
surprised and excited okay so this is
what dreams are made I know I'm
obviously excited I love all the fun how
many times did you practice in here I
can't not do it
is there a chance we could get like a
remix of this is what dreams are made of
a new musical number the possibilities
are endless
you know okay I have a lot of people
sending pitches one of my makeup artists
was like here's where so-and-so ended up
here's the plot for that here's what
happened with these two I'm like you're
great like we need you on the riders
team like you have a very clear vision
of what has been going on and I like it
so you know any and all pictures are
available where early stages we want a
musical number we want Isabella and
Lizzie to reunite
now how do we balance younger and Lizzie
you know what they've been lovely to
each other so you know obviously I had
to get the blessing from TV Landon from
Darren and everyone was like oh yes
we're excited for you so I think it's
gonna be a little challenging you know
like mom is my number one rule in life
and so I'm a little worried but you know
we're gonna we're gonna make it all
happen I think that Liz he's gonna shoot
here and then I'm gonna go to New York
and shoot shoot a season of younger and
then I don't know I just keep keep
juggling it you know amazing so excited
thanks so much I'm excited Oh does your
son wash Alyssa Lizzie McGuire so he's
seen some clips on YouTube and he is
like I think he's he's getting into it
he's still a little young he's seven and
he's really into Marvel so everyone
that's been like hanging around here
today I'm like Luke what would be losing
his mind I don't even think I could tell
him that I'm here and then I like took
pictures with all of these like Marvel
stars but I don't know he's I'm I'm
pretty cool and like he I think he likes
seeing me at an age closer to his you
know and it's all on TV so
[Music]